mil soldados estadounidenses se enviarán
de alemania a rumanía y 2000 de carolina
del norte concretamente de la base fort
bragg a alemania estos movimientos según
el portavoz del pentágono john kirby se
dan por un lado porque en las últimas 24
horas
vladimir putin ha hecho movimientos
militares en lugares en regiones
estratégicas de rusia
cercanas al mediterráneo el atlántico
norte y a bielorrusia y también para
apoyar los países aliados de la otan en
caso de un eventual ataque ruso a
ucrania john kirby también aseguró que
estos movimientos de estas 3.000 tropas
no tienen nada que ver con las 8500
tropas que están listas para ser
desplegadas en el futuro también dijo
que no este movimiento de estas 3.000
tropas no es de forma definitiva y que
en los próximos días podrían darse más
movimientos de tropas
como bien has dicho se podrían dar más
movimientos de tropas y que otras
medidas está considerando washington
para evitar un ataque de rusia sobre
ucrania
de forma preventiva el congreso y el
tanto los demócratas como republicanos
están considerando la madre de las
tensiones así lo llamó el presidente del
comité de relaciones exteriores del
senado bob menéndez
estas sanciones serían por un lado una
sanción al gasoducto nord stream goes
que va de rusia a alemania y por otro
lado sanciones específicas a oficiales
rusos que según bob menéndez pues
tendrían grandes efectos en la economía
de rusia